this only are not ready for that yeah a
level of immaturity yeah I got her
checkmate yeah and then she looked at me
she's like yeah I doing him up and when
she said that
oh oh and I just started and she just
turned around and walked away didn't
even give me a chance to rebuttal I just
started dying although obviously got me
dude in five four three two one what's
up everybody welcome to another episode
of the genius brain podcast we have our
very special guest Patrick T Riley
stand-up comic extraordinaire and then
we have this guy Nick the [ __ ]
Davis assistant train conductor done the
train conductor new fanny pack every
time how many fanny packs do ya how many
do you have this is only I only have one
other one okay so don't even say that
you really yeah and I've been wearing
this for the past like eight months why
so defensive bro your failure to notice
these things and I told you I got a new
fanny pack and you don't even care dude
your even care no announcement made you
don't even got any time a new fanny pack
man no this is this is a cool one tell
it to my guy Marlon he's the one that
gave it to me so the front pocket I have
chapstick cool thank you that one pocket
is dedicated just a stick okay until you
keys I have two different types of hand
sanitizer before you know I got already
putting tampons that's a big pocket I'm
sorry those but you know like when is
rolled up Napa there's a general rule
for fanny packs especially for like
having it look good your fanny pack is
about a good 7 inches too big your that
should have a big ass well I'm
compensating for something I have a
checkbook in here too you write checks
well I don't know I think I forgot to
take it out so I have a checkbook in
here is that to be a retirement function
dude this is for function why don't you
burn um I got to write a check dude you
write checks in this dude no of course
not I might years old [ __ ] the real
second ages
no I I think I I have I forgot to take
it out you had the shitty thing is like
all this stuff started going online like
these direct deposit stuff but then
what's the call I think eight years ago
I bought like ten thousand checks from
Costco I'll never need to re-up on
checks ever again how much did that cost
you like fifty bucks
it wasn't much Costco is pretty cheap
and they're like legit I got the whole
leather binder for and everything that
[ __ ] hasn't been touched in five years
there's nobody takes check yeah oh my
god I wish there's so much money let's
just start a company you start on
payroll
I'd be so rich right now if I didn't buy
all those checks it's like when people
buy a wallet to put their money in but
they but the wallet cost like $600 so
now they have no more money to put it in
like a pen money that much louis vats in
one spot was the tongue do man that [ __ ]
brother what what what's like the one
like say you had so much money what's
the one name brand that you would like
by yourself in terms of what anything
maybe like say like listen to a lot of
questions yeah like you know something
like something like a wallet go mmm let
me let me think like an unnecessary i
probably get me a set of that what sick
i forgot what the the type of leather it
is it's like the damn e air damn you a
dog so I was so out of my league the new
Eva time had ever heard a baton the look
beautiful duffel
those are pretty yeah cuz I feel like
that's in part of being bougie but also
kind of hood at the same time so I would
get the Louis duffel nice and then I
would get the the Louie fanny pack oh
right because I think I've trained
enough now when somebody calls me a
[ __ ] loser like a sock in the face
fanny pack loser that's funny boy PI you
didn't know I hear this be a podcast
your biggest weakness [ __ ] I got
bully bug I just wait for you to keep
what would you buy then if you add that
type of [ __ ] you Mustaine I'll do the
same whatever no no no no but you do not
get to have that bag because I don't
want to speak wins you know what I don't
I think I'd have a really hard time cuz
how much does are those bags it's like I
I think the doubles like five grand I
might be low-balling it yeah damn girl I
don't know man I don't think I could
really bring myself to buy something
like that I just said in this world yeah
you have expendable money you can yeah
and you have to buy something okay two
things
I got an O Lord I got to learn more
about fashion and all that stuff first
and then second I'll probably do you
like man I'm like really not imaginative
at all
iYou know what else do you know shoes
okay shoes shoes I like like to blame
like cheap shoes though you know what
I'll get a pair like Jordan ones those
are cool air which one the one from the
last dance do you guys well there's a
konso last dance
yeah - oh yeah Oh G once I don't they're
like a hundred okay no one more thing
one more thing what would you get um
this guy is the worst what if person
ever yeah dude I'm like I'm bad what am
I gave you a million dollars what would
you do with AirPlay invest in oh I got
taxes right so I'm gonna make sure I
save enough for tax like shut the [ __ ]
up I hate you so much
the proposition I have no good yeah
uh-huh I gotta make sure you save some
money for my mom probably Hubbell you uh
probably keeps my up usually I say we're
from a college how much like um you know
I'll probably get like uh dude I haven't
literally have no answer for you that's
the sad part
alright Pat listen someone else I mean I
don't know a lot of fast [ __ ] but I
would definitely get a baller a suit
yeah like a gangster ass like James Bond
type suit like that bang just nice just
oh I know what I don't care like it okay
I want to wear it's brunch you know is
[ __ ] over on anyways bang
Aleksei Rolex Rolex watch I would get a
cool Rolex I think a watch would be cool
ooh rook I mean I would if I had a lot
of money it would be a car for me like a
dope-ass old school muscle car yeah yeah
yeah I feel like if I got a muscle car
people be like what do you think you're
white have a Mustang you eat those Gran
Torino you're gonna cool you don't
actually dude you could be Clint
Eastwood oh that's right get off my lawn
yeah you know Clint Eastwood from that
taught me a lot of racist terms I never
heard of yeah I never heard of a spook
yeah dude a spook is one world oh yeah
what [ __ ] spade I think he's eight
what is that referring to I think that
black folks Oh Oh cuz yeah [ __ ]
because of they would run people over
the tanks yeah that's pretty that's
pretty nice that's pretty [ __ ] pretty
nice that's an intense what the cool the
polish ones in there when he gets into
the racist banter with the polish barber
what does he call what is calm some dumb
[ __ ] sorry and then he'll other words
bang bang bang bang hot dog bratwurst
road things like that no he's our fire
[ __ ] what you know I like the most
likeable racist in that movie you know
he was he was like cuz you're like I get
it he's racist but like he's kind of
cool bigger than that film I heard none
of those people the the Hmong cast
members except for a couple who are
still acting now yeah they weren't
really actors they were just like bong
people of that community and so when I
was watching I was like they're acting
it's not that great yeah it was really
it was the guy the kid that like liked
him or whatever yeah like I remember
there was a scene where he's like
banging on the door and it's literally
the shittiest thing I've ever seen a
rewatch looks at the camera and keep
going yeah I remember this being bad
that was the one where everybody stopped
them was like this is really bad
that's really basic they said that Clint
Eastwood for that movie he was he was
method for the whole time like he was
method acting the whole like boorish I I
think it was just him in between the set
in between he was staying in character
at all time I think that literally they
thought that but it actually it was just
him
is that news not everybody gooks Wow his
his life yeah like one [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
like he's in character wow he is clean
when are we gonna shoot this film it's
like we're shooting it now yeah I knew
that
yeah my [ __ ] did I love that I remember
I was watching I am Legend and there's a
scene where like it's like a flashback
to like his family he's trying to get
there like he shouldn't put him in a
helicopter me like leave or something
and there's like this protest outside of
the helicopter like let us soon cuz they
won't let certain people with like the
little eye skin yeah he had the virus
whatever the [ __ ] and it like zooms in
on this lady that's holding a baby and
she's crying and like there's people
behind you like and there's this one
black dude like to the left of her who
like is laughing and he keeps looking
into the camera like he's like he's like
tryna act mad I was like we could
organize ours right [ __ ] now right
now I think we could do it right now if
they got they got they should we do it
yeah that's act right now I act Beast be
sad alright be said be said hey you're
at the vet your animal oh let's do
scenario [ __ ] I'm a terrible actor Mel I
don't get along alright here we go
these are my acting coaches so you just
why do we always do scenarios when what
am I was first you are married you're in
a very unhappy marriage uh-huh okay it's
raining outside
it is a you've had a long day at work
right huh I'm going to be the woman and
I will be mad at you because I've also
had a shitty day uh-huh you just got
fired but you're scared to tell your
wife so you act emotionally and you lash
at her that is the scene here we go
scene starts door enters you were so
specific a yeah I gotta like I want to
give him some stuff that is no I'm the
guy here I'm your design I'm the word
you're much okay you don't like me give
me that kind of like a nice line VW's
that is I perfect that's why your BBJ
get some backstory I like what we argue
about and like what we're unhappy about
you this is what you have to create as
an act or oh [ __ ] so remember you just
got fired
Wow so I gotta take it in my own hands
yeah you gotta create the universe and I
will I will even help you out I'm gonna
start the scenario okay good
where the [ __ ] have you been Wow I work
all day and I come home and this is how
you talk to me like me taking care of
the kids isn't [ __ ] work
have you ever changed diapers with two
[ __ ] twins before guys maybe if you
eat a [ __ ] salad for once I wouldn't
be so mad when I come home you said
you'd like smashing big cheeks when you
first there I kept these cheeks around
for you
I don't like cellulite but I kept them
nice and pocky for you ain't nervous for
you I'm nervous I'm [ __ ] nerve you
think I want to come home and see that
cellulite on your [ __ ] thighs every
night that Shamer
I do love it though I do love it yeah
you don't love [ __ ] and first of all
look at the lights huh you can't even
pay for the [ __ ] electricity bill
you're a loser you can't provide and
your penis is small Wow amen don't say
penis man your penis is so small it
looks like a laser battery light mmm
disgusting you know what happened to me
today what happened I lost my job and
well deserved because you don't work
here so I bet you do the same [ __ ] over
there
Dyanne [ __ ] you're being a real [ __ ]
[ __ ] right now that you gonna hit me
are you gonna hit me
whoa if you weren't 6 2 and 350 pounds
wow that's a bit of exaggeration I would
have the balls to hit you you didn't
have balls when I met you why would you
have grown them now oh you knew what you
were getting into when you met me and I
was a battle rapper
what are you upset about wow dude that
was great well that was great let's get
house I think he lost when you said you
keeping your cheeks nice big and pocky I
think I don't know I just use that word
my cheeks are fat [ __ ] actually lost I
immediately thought about like the Asian
snack Pocky that's what I thought about
yeah threw me off a little bit yeah I
was a shift you gotta like give me your
heads up I tried I tried it bring it
this time because usually I'm like you
did yeah dude I'm ready to go too this
podcast is brought to you by fiber 2020
is a crazy year especially for
businesses I should know because I am a
business owner and boy did I have to
mention unless minute moves but when I
need last minute work done in a timely
manner I always use Fiverr to hire
free-lance
work because when you need things done
in a jiffy you got to get that freelance
work and listen you could be launching
your own business and you might need
graphic work video work we're
programming whatever you name it go to
fiverr.com and find the freelance work
you need I have used Fiverr for just
about everything especially when it came
to graphics and web designing that's not
something that I'm great at and as a
business owner I do need to understand
how to delegate this work to other
skilled workers and I go to Fiverr to
find those people listen I knew exactly
what I was paying for upfront but no
negotiating needed and specific
deadlines that needed to be met or met
as promised I don't want the hassle and
headache when it comes to hiring people
out and Fiverr had a lot of reliable
people that I could use it was easy I
loved it so check out fiverr.com and
receive 10% off your first order by
using my code g/b find all the digital
services you need in one place at fi ve
our our comm code GB again that's
fiverr.com code GB I'm ready Nick and
Pat now oh right so Pat this is your
coming-out moment Nick is your best
friend since you were 5 years old you
guys are now 22 years old you just
graduated it is graduation day and you
guys have been talking to
smashing poon throughout the whole
[ __ ] year but he's always wondered
why you never went out with him and
you're gonna tell him why is because you
are coming out and you actually have a
crush on him
ooh you guys are in a car and you're
watching a drive-thru movie what is the
movie white chicks time to come out
white chicks yeah it is white chicks mm
for some reason in 2020 you haven't seen
the movie yet at his big play they have
a random screaming uh-huh okay
and go hey so so like I know there looks
like Marlon Wayans as well as a white
chick but like she's he's still pretty
hot in that you know what do you think
wait I'm the gay dude right you say
negation I gave you a log I locked it up
to you you don't even catch the ball
dude
that's a perfect lie that's not excited
good actor bro you can't even play Oh
take the rice Pacific you said it was
well I just took some liberties bro it
was it was it was it plot twist you're
also gay no yeah that was a plot to us
that's not a plot twist that's just your
straight in this scenario I know I'm
strapped I'm only doing the lgbtq+ fans
out there I think it's is it is it gay
pride month this no it's not goodbye
month what I think is gay pride mother I
think it might be I think it is the last
month yeah let's look it up cuz they had
pressure no they had pride the pride
parade yeah LG P because I think June B
is actually celebrating it we're
celebrating for you see the UFC do that
they had like custom walkout shorts and
instead of like the white lettering it
was like in the the pride color
lettering and that was pretty cool I was
like nothing I stopped the lgbtq+
community y'all been through a lot of
[ __ ] and now your voice is gonna be
heard come on
so let's try that again let's try to get
I like the way now we're here bang we're
watching a movie hmm
I'll start there good thanks Nick for
inviting me out to see movie theory
approach it that yeah man you know just
we do this all the time and like why are
you whispering like that because they're
in a car because I I just is my voice do
you making fun of my [ __ ] voice well
it's usually don't talk like that and
that's why I just thought it was kind of
weird but this movies pretty good right
yes it was great yeah loves Vanessa
Carlton I love this song yeah you know
what Cruz is so jacked Nick I gotta I
gotta be honest we just graduated you've
been a close friend of mine for a long
time and I know you think it's weird
that it never came out with you and you
never really seen me with a girlfriend
but I didn't know how to say this but
all those times when we were younger
we'd have sleepovers and we'd sleep in
the same bed yeah you thought you felt
something poking your leg and I told you
is the Xbox controller because we just
got done playing Halo to it it was
actually my dick and because I was hard
and I'm gay and I like you so you're
telling me that one time two years ago
yeah when you slept over on my house and
I woke up and you had your hand around
my dick and you said you were
sleepwalking you're telling me this is a
lie
or was it were you actually sleepwalking
did you do that in your sleep or did you
that on purpose man I need to know that
time I was sleepwalking but I wanted to
do that while I was awake all right well
thank you for being honest with me I
appreciate that but um I like you dude
all right well let's do this man Neri oh
yeah dude you know what's crazy dude is
actually I did have a homie I'm not
gonna say any names talk about this no
we have okay this is one of the best
stories of all time so he's on the
homies that we grew up with and we've
long well at first so he was like this
like kind
a Mexican like bugged-out dude and so he
had these crazy upbringing crazy stories
over like damn dude like this dude's a
hardcore ass dude and then little by
little like like oh he would spend the
night and [ __ ] and like my house
everyone used to crash there and like he
would sleep sleep next to different
dudes different nights and there's no
order this [ __ ] you just sleep wherever
you sleep in the sleeping bag
sometimes you sleep next Nick sometimes
you sleep next to Alex whatever payment
but little by little like the first
story came out from one of our homies he
came out he's a man I got was sleeping
next to so-and-so and he was he was grab
my dick dude like what like I woke up
and like I felt some like kind of
touching my dick and we were all like
what like Tori was the inspiration for
AZ like your mouth or like no way we
laughed for like crazy and then a week
later
hey man I was suplex they sound so and
like that happened to like what the [ __ ]
and then little by little like all the
homies I had their story and one day he
slept next he was on the floor and he
was a man my back hurts do you mind if I
sleep on the bed with you and I was like
yeah I don't care
oh sleeping and then I felt I woke up
cuz I felt like I felt like this and I
was like and I woke up and I smack this
and I was like you know what the [ __ ]
are you doing man and he like he was
like woke up oh sorry like I thought it
was the TV remote like I thought was the
TV might thank you first of all thank
you no how long were you touching my
dick before you realize that like it
wasn't the TV remote right he was doing
like V remote has a weird mushroom shape
do I have twisties like this was his
thumb and [ __ ] [ __ ] so we always made
fun of him for it and we all he hasn't
come out of the closet but we're pretty
sure he's gay because we're friends I
mean he molested us but we're still
friends but like out of like out of a
group of like ten dudes out of the group
of 10 dude all 10 of another story and
this dude used to always come up to me
and like I'd always come I wasn't around
as much but I would come around a lot
and everybody in the group knew that
like I didn't drink yeah and now
everyone's aw come on Nikola and I would
never drink right and every time we hung
and he was always there when we go kick
it and he'd always be like a man like
you want you wanna grab a beer like I'll
grab a beer with you and I was like oh
man I actually don't drink what if I put
the shot in my mouth and i pass
over to you I don't like well I guess I
have to get rude but like he would he
would always just be like every time I
see him and it wasn't like I wouldn't
see him after like a month or two yeah
like every other weekend maybe I'd go
yeah I mean like you want to drink like
you want it sure you don't a beer you
always be like enticing me to like grab
a beer like hey you wanna grab a beer
like oh man like err have a beer with me
have a beer with me he'd be like really
pushy to the point where I was like
after a while I realized I was like this
is and then after hearing their stories
dude I don't know how like cuz because
of jail if we look no he's not but I
would look back like he actually like
would molest us and we were always like
we would just make fun of him and he'd
get mad and but like we were at all like
we never were like hey don't come around
like yeah so like he's the huh you would
always kick it like well like every
would be to the point like we'd be at a
party it is so [ __ ] weird this whole
dynamic but we had a party and like
someone would crash like in the other
room someone just like not rob and then
we would like beep like playing beer
pong or something and then we'd be like
okay where's so-and-so and then be like
wait where the [ __ ] is so-and-so and
then we'd all run in the room was like
what the [ __ ] are you doing man oh no
I'm just checking on them you know lava
and then you would leave and then we're
like a but he's still the homie it's not
so weird bill with like guys cuz if you
look at a bet like this right I feel
like guys are so hard weird right when
you think about that situation so you
guys got molested yeah but for some
reason in a guy's head it's like it
there's a safety thing it's like well if
he really did something I'd [ __ ] my
exact exact know and one of our homies
did that like I guess he was the guy in
question was sleeping on the floor and
the homie was stepping over him so I
grabbed something and he stepped over
one time and he felt the hand go inside
his basketball shirt and and and he
slapped the [ __ ] hand was like I
slapped him in the face
oh that's what happened twice didn't
happened once I don't know I just know
that he slapped in the face was like yo
what the [ __ ] are you doing and I guess
he pretended to like be asleep whenever
one night we're all hanging out and okay
is the worst molester on my leg you need
to get better at your molestia
your technique is terrible yeah yeah
it's like just laughs the baby goes
it's not very efficient and I I guess
another one over homies and he was
sleeping on a bunk bed and he was
reaching up I'm trying like a reach
verse why does he keep doing it and
during the sleep time I don't know the
only time we heard all bust his balls
and he would stuff but after a while it
did stop yeah so that's why I was trying
to say it was a condition where it like
grabbing condition in the middle and my
[Laughter]
deceased like that's so not a cool thing
to do older we lighting to do a good
thing to do to my friend yeah you don't
always be like you guys got molested
that's crazy yeah so and then we would I
remember one night we were all kicking
it we're all taking it and we're all
sharing our stories about this dude
and it was there and then she was like
oh my god like the guys that's not okay
like cuz you know she'll just laugh
she's a social worker so she's like her
mind is in that space and she's like
that's not okay like he can't be doing
that to you guys and then we were like
yeah whatever the next day we went to
Disneyland and then we it was like 6
p.m. and that's me and TIFF and we just
got off cars land and we just got off
and we're about to walk out she goes I
don't want you hanging out with blank
anymore and I was like what she goes
it's just I was thinking about it and it
just really bothers me that he was doing
that to you guys that I just I just
don't him around like do you think you
could stop him feature if he tries that
to you like if he does that if you try
something on you I was like yeah I would
imagine so but like why are you bring
this up now like this is really like on
your mind huh no I was just thinking
about it like I'm just thinking about
I've been thinking about all day this
poor girl was thinking about how like
[ __ ] I just find a little buzz so
it's so odd because this is such a very
interesting social experiment about how
that sexual assault thing happens to a
guy and when it means to a guy versus a
girl right because if you put it in the
in this because I keep on reading these
comments where guys right mmm well if
that happened to a guy nobody would care
mama my blob but I but it goes to show
is that for a woman a woman would care
for the guy but it's the guys that don't
care because they don't feel an
immediate sense of danger exactly right
here is so interesting because I keep on
reading this this argument on Twitter
one
talk about this topic specifically they
go oh if a guy did that stuff girls
wouldn't care
I think girls would care because they
empathize they see that situation of it
happening that if they in the same
chance but then a guy has this thing of
like I don't know if it's because if
it's like a machismo thing or because we
joke about it or we laugh about it a lot
or maybe just cuz we just feel safe that
if he does if he really had some ill
intent I can break your [ __ ] arm
that's how I feel yeah it was like weird
enough to be like this is weird but then
like the way we we were just make all
make fun of them because it was like
what we're gonna clown you now cuz like
you can't be doing that
yeah and times yeah and then it was like
kind of like I don't I don't really know
we were just like really like definitely
it wasn't until like a couple years ago
where we started to be like the coolest
thing to do to your boy yes especially
if it's like on the context of they're
not okay with it and it's without
consent and then you start doing it
that's so that guys a little molester
yeah yeah there's a little mustard what
in the butt it's so funny how all you
guys kind of like had your own moments
like slap the [ __ ] out of yeah but then
it was like like we're still like if he
if I saw him I talked to him yeah cuz
you didn't feel who knows what what he
was going I don't know what the [ __ ] was
going to do that but that happened I was
having a friend he's a friend you know
that happened I wonder what if that what
behavior still continues and what he
does now like it like every group that
he goes to he just he's gonna slap the
face wish technique jig was up so he was
like I gotta find a new group of friends
to try this for you just come out the
[ __ ] closet and develop healthy
relation if he was doing that in hopes
that one of you was getting he might
have been he might have been like I said
I'll marry I was like lift missed us is
like okay I'm sure it's a weird place to
navigate right it's like trying to
figure out like blood flow you're the
one you felt it is so [ __ ] weird man
you know and all I really would
we're all pretty young to write like
1718 yeah there's a gray area there you
know obviously it's not okay but at the
same time it's like weird as [ __ ] yeah
you could understand like okay this is
kinda funny I just realize like a month
ago that yeah that's so uh like why
don't we keep kicking it you know any
yet but I still do like he is a good
like I don't know it's the weirdest
thing it still goes over your head or
sometimes it's just like you don't put
the pieces together after like the in
the grand scheme of things when you
start actually yes we're all telling
these stories not like and you guys
would always tell these stories yeah
because it's like if you're getting a
less dude you're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] man yeah yeah this is like a really
funny stand-up set something really
funny stand-up said by the same time was
the real story is always like but it's
funny it's funny for us what's funny for
you guys cuz you guys you guys it's your
guys's experience it's just like he was
like totally not cool act or still cool
yeah and it's just like we just clown
you I don't think see this is what is it
weird that I'm like I'm trying to come
in here with like a man when I was I got
molested do and they're like by who
well there I was out with that school
right and I had some peanut butter and
jelly and he's kind of made a teacher
was like there's so can I have some of
the peanut butter and jelly right and I
was like sure miss miss Chang she was
like oh well I'm just gonna put it on
your lip and then I'm gonna paste it off
your lip and I was like that's weird
yeah I too and one of you it's like are
you trying to do youtuber does DJ use
you don't have to like joint it's fine
it's like you know I don't know I I do i
to have done this it's like that girl
that I roasted on [ __ ] Instagram what
she was like I've been racially profiled
before it was it was the first video you
did I forgot her name but she's a Korean
girl with fake tits oh okay yeah you
know she's like she's like first of all
apparently you have no idea how many
people dislike her in general because
there's people who have worked with her
in like the import modeling world and
they said she's literally the dumbest
person they've ever met somebody told me
the story about her where she they
literally met her at a club and she was
like trying to get Fame
from like this this club guy so she kept
on offering a threesome for any [ __ ]
like that
whoa terrible stories about like yo this
girl is a [ __ ] you go straight to
threesome yeah she's she's a and you
know I the reason why I didn't do a
follow-up video because she kept on
going hard at it I think she's like
mentally on her so now I just feel like
a bully so I didn't want to give her any
more attention but you know if she gets
hit by car and dies
my piss on the grave but you know
something like that she was saying some
crazy [ __ ] yeah she was calling yes a
little bit of the clip she was dancin
wall [ __ ] and also on top of that it's
like whenever you hear somebody that
starts a conversation when they're about
to talk about something serious and they
start by saying I am like everyone knows
me like I'm the best very person you're
not like I'm very humble I'm very giving
if you get to know me bah blah blah
whatever anybody says that there's
batshit crazy not yeah something is off
cuz nobody with that's actually caring
or humble would ever start a
conversation to get you to listen to
what I'm saying by saying hey I am all
these qualities these great qualities
that cure my resume yeah that's me and
it's like no dude that's not how that
[ __ ] works that [ __ ] has earned yeah if
you're a good person people generally
exactly do they know a lot bro they can
see it they can see it you think you're
a good person that's questionable yeah
not really I think you're too good of a
person dude you need to have a little
you have a backbone dude yeah yeah [ __ ]
some people over every now and there yes
I don't think you do I feel like I don't
give enough I think it's coming out like
over time I feel like you normally don't
one thing that in my mind though like
recently is like I feel like I don't
give enough to the people that like take
care of me it's like Holmes you know
like a lot of people a lot of people
like whom I just don't know how to like
I don't know what ails I'm just common
we're trying to talk with my hands and
being like intellectual and things like
that but you know you're is it your
sisters that you treat like [ __ ] on a
daily base waterboard them I spit on
them all these things to them no not not
not particularly them but just other
people like won't you do better huh yeah
yeah yeah why don't you [ __ ] do
better excuse me before you like
assassinate my character I just need you
to know that like I am a very good
person humble I'm not
I have a plan I have so many black
friends oh my friends Oh No
and give me names Dabangg Paulo when
someone says I have plenty of black
friends you're like hey well what a
weird like thing yeah okay
especially flowing like this you know
yeah but whatever it is what it is the
thing about you I think you are a nice
person just you just like uh you're too
nice sometimes that's the only thing and
you gotta stand up for yourself but I
think I have seen that coming out he
gets pushed to the edge so [ __ ] far
dude and you could see the cliff you
just choose to get scooted over there
like I'm like just just one more second
maybe something good will happen before
I get pushed off the cliff yeah
that's why my need to set those
[ __ ] boundaries man setting
boundaries with people that's a
soul-satisfying thing I I do all the
time yeah oh I know who you are I know
what I'm gonna get out of this
relationship cut it off right here I
expect nothing more for you if you do
give me more than what I expected
that's the bonus on your end right other
than that sight is what it is yeah you
like to get [ __ ] [ __ ] over see a
therapist I think I should be maybe you
think I should but I mean you're aware
of the problem which is good I think you
should just to work on it you know
there's always little instances where
you can like you know pry it's like a
like working out like those are
situations where if somebody's
infringing a little bit and it bothers
you then just say just say that
sometimes in the moment I do overanalyze
things I think I think it over analyze
things to the point where I give people
an out a little too much and I think I
empathize with people a little too much
and I think that kind of maybe gets me
in this weird dialog where I'm like oh
well maybe you know yeah I don't think
empathy is a problem I think empathy
becomes an issue when it starts to
affect your life in a negative way right
empathy is something that you should be
able to use to understand somebody
situation so you guys couldn't meet on a
common ground right but when when that
relationship starts taking from you and
it's just that this give give give and
take take take and there's nothing that
happens that's not empathy either it's
just like a disguise for you not wanting
to say something you know yeah I'm not
real you know I'm gonna start telling
people to [ __ ] off more I should start
doing that okay well it's just is that a
good start let's go someone in between
there huh
yeah yeah yeah I think the way I Drive
sometimes in the way like I get road
rage I think I'll try to I think I
should try to do that and everyday you
should just practice being more honest
about what you're actually thinking you
know I know I'm actually I do actually
try to do that and I actually try to
tell people like look dude like this is
where I stand as I feel about certain
things and I try to leave and I try to
be as honest as possible with certain
people actually with most people I try
because you and I had the opposite
problem I say my opinion when it's not
needed hurt feelings a lot I thought my
opinion and I need a little bit of your
big pull it back like I'll walk into a
room why we're great with each other
look at that blouse ugly huh terrible
she so today's sermon is gonna start
he's a minister he came out you do your
makeup with your knuckles today amazing
so today we're gonna learn about empathy
and time in place Psalms 32 psalm 32 mmm
yeah everyone has a thing I mean
everyone's got the thing to work on it's
interesting when I hear you guys say
that stuff because I think I think
you're right
yeah I mean it's just an observation
shut the [ __ ] up dude fine I got it Oh
see boom oh okay let's go somewhere in
between that huh I'm healed baby yeah
dude up I just jump off a bridge or
something what were you guys doing today
on this fine Friday night you're
literally one of the nicest people I
ever met in my life thank you I
appreciate it look too nice though yeah
maybe I should not be as nice as I
should be well you just need to have
teeth in the right situation yeah you
know what yes okay hate to say what the
[ __ ] is know what's crazy sometimes when
I do get like really upset and I
actually speak out on certain things
everybody looks at me like what the [ __ ]
you know cuz sometimes I do that's
because you already put yourself in a
subservient position constantly so that
they expect that to be the norm so you
know people are just walking over you
all the time and the reason why
sometimes people like you might be
because they are walking over you so you
are playing that position that they
prefer in their life it yeah this is
what I need well hey you're under my
thumb and I only like you when you're
here but when you
speak up for yourself and you're not
under their thumb anymore they go oh now
you're being an [ __ ] but it's really
just I'm just speaking my mind and I
don't like the way that you're treating
me you know that's true that's actually
you know and also hey bro do you live in
my house dog mmm
and you leave my [ __ ] house hey bro
do you know me also this guy [ __ ]
know who I am
hey what am I saying dude she's gonna be
like thank you that's what she's gonna
say it's true though honestly and to if
you if you don't speak up you're [ __ ]
me that's why you've blow up in the
[ __ ] car cuz you you don't have any
high tide you don't release it when the
time's right and you just we've actually
talked about shields up and then you
blow up on somebody we've had a lot of
sovereign appropriate yeah we've had a
lot of conversations about the same [ __ ]
where we talk about how we need to like
release in certain positions a certain
like situations and I feel like I do the
ladder I kind of hold it in a little bit
and I'm like you know whatever like I
kind of turned the other cheek but it
comes out the way cuz duh I mean what's
the whole point of like you get
confronted by somebody that pisses you
off and you go oh my mouth are cold it's
okay and with the empathy and then you
walk outside broke a ladybug lands on
your nose and you're like you [ __ ]
you know what's the doesn't make any
sense like you gotta you gotta make sure
that your anger goes in the right way
you think something was spit on my mouth
I would not do anything if I did you'd
be like okay if you walk that way I
think that's exactly what you would do
well alright then yeah cuz I I know I
had an instance to where I blew up
recently on a Karen and I didn't and I
felt like if I was the story in person I
told you the story but it was I was so I
was before I got this office office
office before I got in this office I was
gonna go back to little Armenia Glendale
uh-huh and because it was a nice office
that was about this price but it's like
three times the size the reason why I
chose not to get it because an office
three times
sighs I would have to fill it out what's
the whole point my this office is
perfectly fine right and then when I
when I before I walked into the office
there was a lady I was on my phone I
looked up she wasn't backing out and I
went for and she started backing out she
almost hits me I'm like oh cool whatever
and I look at my phone turn it off I
start walking and she goes she goes you
should probably look up when you're on
your phone there's people driving here
oh and you know this is during a time
where the where the come flew the COBE
[ __ ] was happening and I was on edge I
was not having it and so I looked at her
and I was like you're in the car I'm a
pedestrian you're supposed to watch out
for my safety you weren't coming out so
I walked I wasn't I was aware that you
were there right usually goes I have the
right away right and she goes okay and
she rolls her eyes and I was like what
the [ __ ] I was like you're in the
[ __ ] car she goes do you like
apparently you don't know Road rules
I said the [ __ ] you say to me [ __ ]
Howard aah like I went red yeah and I
literally so wrong yeah now it's like
hundreds enter and I look at I was like
you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] I was like so so
this is what it is that's what I mean I
was like you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] so if
you're in the middle of the [ __ ] Road
right you drive off you hit somebody
else is it the other cars fault for
being there I was like you have to watch
you're the one going into the other lane
same situation here when you're backing
out you have to look at the pedestrian
that's coming out and walking if you're
at all
shut the [ __ ] up and so I literally just
start screaming she goes okay whatever
she starts laughing I'm like cool so I
just stood right behind a car and I was
like I got about thirty minutes before I
have to meet this guy so I'm standing
right here and then she just starts
blazing her music she goes you ask them
Oh rolls up the windows start blazing or
music I'm not what you listening to I
don't [ __ ] remember but I was I just
stood there
[Applause]
[ __ ] smash mouth is like joke's on
you brother
she listen to Tupac that's why I say
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
know so I stood there for not 30 minutes
but it's like a good maybe like 10
minutes or some [ __ ] like that very and
I just waited and she's just coming you
ask to move out so I don't gotta go
anyway
you could run me over if you like and I
just waited and waited and waited just
so I just cuz I knew then she the only
way she was leaving she ran me over and
if she ran me over I had to follow food
so tired and all I did and I just when I
just finally decided to move I [ __ ]
press my middle finger up on her window
as she was turning out she drove off
yeah do that you know some people
deserve it it's got tired of that [ __ ]
it's just like that was like the second
like white lady that just decided that
she could just say whatever the [ __ ] to
me because that Kobe thing yeah you know
right when that Cova situation happened
it was like green light on asian people
yeah for I'm like hmm I thought y'all
were really cool what the [ __ ] so
whatever that was inside then this whole
time is just leaked all the [ __ ] out
that happened to my buddy Kenny he was
at the supermarket we've talked to we've
talked the legend of Kenny on this
pocket I seen Kenny peanut children for
no reason he's got a darkness and the
guy that way I need a little bit I can't
eat yeah I always do I always tell Kenny
I'm like man Kenny this I need some of
you and me darkness like that wanna be
the first wanna be the first anyway so
he was at a supermarket and there's
white dude some older white gentleman
they were in line to check out I like a
Ralph's or something and he and I guess
he was like he said something under his
breath like oh yeah like get this guy
with kovalev me I don't want covin baba
take Kenny - Kenny and then Kenny was
like the worst decision yeah I think
Kenny was like [ __ ] you you fat [ __ ]
like what he's like you talking to me
that way like what the [ __ ] wrong with
you I don't have kovin [ __ ] like
what are you talking about and everyone
was like sir please like stop it had a
separate them so they put him in two
different lines and then he was still
talking [ __ ] to the guy in the other
line and he was like he's like heart
disease is gonna kill you before cove it
ever will you fat [ __ ] and the guy that
worked there was like sir please stop
like he's not say anything to you
anymore like just leave them alone okay
that's
why I don't understand when people talk
[ __ ] it's like you better be ready yeah
exactly yeah I don't talk [ __ ] to
anybody unless it's I'm ready to like go
all the way yeah you never know who the
[ __ ] you're talkin [ __ ] to this dude
could just start swinging at you you
don't know like I don't get out of line
unless it's Barry you know what I mean
not at least not in a disrespectful way
like if that guy was like hey do you
mind keeping your distance
who knows how Kenny would have reacted
to that you know maybe he would have
still got pissed who the [ __ ] knows but
I mean at least that's a not like get
your what'd he say get your co would ask
what he was like he's like I forgot
actually what he said he said something
about how he has covetous I'm like yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's cold I mean like
right there when you said that what did
you think was going to happen
Yeah right like what did you think he
was Kenny's gonna he's like my size
you know just fit dude and a killer I
mean he was that he was that his uh he
lives in a complex don't like that and I
guess he was wearing his mask and he was
on the treadmill and the guy next to him
I guess was was probably two travels
away I think Kenny I guess he like
coughed and his mask or some like that
you guys think I was like what the [ __ ]
is that Kovach off and he goes this is a
marijuana cough sir comes back on the
other trail he's like I just [ __ ] tune
them out I was like wow that's all he
got huh Wow cause he already blew off
steam at the other he was already kind
of [ __ ] I'm gonna do that Ralph dude ya
got a [ __ ] on the guy at Ralph's mm-hmm
just speak your mind I think you just
need to speak your mind yeah you know
what yeah you're in those situations
where you feel like I'm being [ __ ]
with like just honestly you don't even
have to get crazy and blow the [ __ ] up
yeah just say what the [ __ ] is on your
mind man Kenny story's way cooler than
mine because I attacked the lady and
he's like the grown man no but she
deserved that though because and you
didn't do anything to her well
absolutely you're like me like I'm gonna
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of you [ __ ]
like you weren't doing anything like
that cuz I wasn't crazy that had been a
little much like alright David or
locking racist [ __ ] yeah but the same
time like what she got was what she
deserved okay sure she probably woulda
done the same [ __ ] to you oh good behind
your car what I wanted to do was [ __ ]
slash her [ __ ] tires yeah remember
got her plates right you got her VIN
number I remember a while ago I was like
nails in her tire 18 at the time and
this is one like my but weed first
started driving one of my buddies had a
car and we went to Rite Aid and there
was a situation where the she was a
Karen she was we're like here I love
in the inner car and there was like a
mix-up about like who you know how long
you're on the sidewalk and you're like
who moves left right or whatever the
[ __ ] so it was like we didn't know who
was going and then somehow her and my
buddy got into words right and she said
some [ __ ] like watch where the [ __ ] you
going bah a lot they started getting
heated right so my buddy gets out of the
car
and like she gets in his face like you
love a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] like in his
face and he's like woah [ __ ]
and so I start talking [ __ ] to her out
of the backseat of the car like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like I just started to though me
write all my Xbox Live [ __ ] talking
training like I used to [ __ ] an old
[ __ ] fart you fart dust right I'm just
saying whatever the [ __ ] back she's like
what and I she's like you skinny
[ __ ] she starts going off on me
right and so we're like having this
battle and it the way it ended she was
like in her late 50s early 60s and I old
[ __ ] you look like you got a dick right
that's what I told her and I was like
this old ladies are not ready for that
yeah a level of immaturity yeah I got
her checkmate yeah and then she looked
at me and she's like yeah I do and I'm
gonna [ __ ] you in the ass with it and
what you said that oh oh and I just
started and she just turned around and
walked away didn't even give me a chance
to rebuttal I just started dying all
they obviously got me dude how'd you
read up there she's like what see my
place later
like she judo Dwight cuz I was like I
got I hear where they're like yo [ __ ]
you late you got a dick and she's like
yeah I do sort of then walks off with a
little ride a bag all this one-hitter
quitter bro yeah I think about it from
time when I got away you know fall when
the leaves were falling I thought about
that woman yeah parking lot what she
told me
I would [ __ ] your mother opponents ready
what was that in South Pasadena in a
parking lot right yes that's hilarious
before I say [ __ ] and they're not ready
for it when I when I moved here and my
job
was you know not a very scary looking
dude so like I you know and IKEA in
Burbank the original one it was such a
[ __ ] to get stuff loaded up because you
just had that small little parking lot
where you can load your [ __ ] up and so
there was a parking spot that I clearly
had guy went around me to just took the
spot and I was like what the [ __ ] and I
was like excuse me it's like you know
you can't do that I was gonna Park you
right he was like are you gonna come out
to help me load my stuff and not Wow and
the [ __ ] rays that came out of me and
I really got out and I had like that
little you know IKEA hammer set that I
bought let me go to the hammer I went to
his [ __ ] headlight because like whoa
whoa whoa whoa I was like get the [ __ ]
out the spot right now i'ma bust your
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right this guy's he's a
big guy he was yoke I thought he was
ready to fight I actually had the hammer
cuz I'll I was scared of him cuz he was
huge yeah sounds like I gotta use his
hammer and I spiked his [ __ ] [ __ ]
skull up it it's the housing it like
he's a big [ __ ] dude unform it able I
am compared to this joke - [ __ ] giant
round I gotta bring your a-game yes I
had that and everybody knows that David
specialty is weapons I have I have a kid
yeah talk to the kid that got stabbed
talk to that mobilizers so what I always
tell people - I think people understand
like how impoverished I grew up so it's
like I was scared a lot of the times
it's like oh [ __ ] like I'm not a scaredy
looking dude but that's the thing it's
like you've been in those positions
before where you have to I don't have
like when you come into a situation
where I I'm talking [ __ ] to somebody
that [ __ ] me over I'm not thinking
like oh we're gonna have some words I'm
gonna walk away it's all her it's all in
no it's like no yeah I bet you this guy
would kill me if you wanted to what are
you gonna try to [ __ ] kill me I am
cool hammer your [ __ ] face open yeah
so you know really I thought he was
about it and then he let what the [ __ ]
are you doing right and I'm like imma
bust your [ __ ] [ __ ] that imma bust
you in the [ __ ] face after so I was
enraged and the guy just backed his [ __ ]
out but it's like why the [ __ ] would you
do that to me why what are we yeah why
yeah make why would you want to escalate
this joke that he made that made me feel
so small it was like oh I guess you're
gonna come out and help me move my stuff
and I'm like but you know that you took
my [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
there's a tiny little hammer - but all
those thing it was like imma bust
can taillights out and I'm a [ __ ]
crack him in the head yeah what's also
just that ways for a lot of people like
they just say [ __ ] but when they see
someone really about it it's like a lot
of people aren't with you white guy
of course big ol white dude he was yoked
though like yeah honestly if you wanted
to [ __ ] me up you probably could have
yeah I was kind of shocked that he
backed down so fast but for a lot of
that's why I'm saying for a lot of
people it's like it's been squeezed like
big old dudes sometimes like that it's
like they get away with just
intimidating people so fast now like
when someone is down and they look how
they look they're like ah best to be
with what I had a [ __ ] white Camry at
the time yeah I my little [ __ ]
plastic glasses I was like [ __ ] I
wouldn't understand
sometimes when I go back and I look at
my photos on my ignored it you would
bully dude I would bow lead you I wonder
him build a time machine just so you go
back as a kid and then steal my own less
money give me that [ __ ] [ __ ] loser
when I was a kid I remember green man it
was me [ __ ] I don't know about
that [ __ ] I don't understand why people
want to take it there and they want the
most annoying thing is when they start
something and they go what why are you
being such an [ __ ] oh oh yeah that's
like that's a power dynamic thing huh
they feel like they're better than you
but I feel like they can get it away
with [ __ ] cuz you won't do anything cuz
did you see the video I have plenty of
the so basically this lady will call her
Karen of course Karen cut this dude off
any confront her he was like what the
[ __ ] why did you just starts freaking
out she goes don't hit me no I'm so
scared please somebody save me
but everybody watched what she did when
she flipped them off and they're like no
yeah you provoked him yeah what the [ __ ]
but she was she was basically what she's
doing is she sees his black guy and she
knows that if she cause she's the old
white lady she's gonna cause a scene
like Amy Cooper yeah she's trying to get
this black dude killed right you know
same same thing with that lady Amy
Cooper she saw the guy she goes you're
trying you're gonna assault me you're
gonna hurt me because she knows what
she's doing yeah you know and that's
that's the biggest problem there yeah
the fact that she's able to kind of go
into this character and you know if we
weren't in the 20th century 21st 21st
century and we now have [ __ ] phones
and cameras to record this yeah it's his
word and we all know how that goes
because there are probably less layered
right number
it's it's a representation of one this
lady knows what she's doing and she
knows that she can get away with it
and number two it's a reflection of the
views of the police force and this
country cuz you know for a fact that
video wasn't there yeah you know it mom
yeah you know she's really yeah exactly
so it's a reflection of two things and
this happened on multiple occasions yeah
so people can't deny that within this
police force there's something [ __ ]
wrong here like oh yeah making sense
like the UH the video you were tell me
about but the kid that was an RA for
this University anyway picking up trash
outside and the cop comes up to him and
it's just like badgering him right oh
yeah that's terrible and it's just like
Judy is telling you he's like a he's
like a dorm RA or he lives in that that
student complex or whatever and then he
he's picking up trash putting it into
the bucket and he will [ __ ] works
there and he lives there the cops like
hey so I heard there's somebody
lawyering out here or whatever and do
you live here he goes yeah he doesn't be
addressed he goes well what's your room
because I actually don't have to tell
you that yeah I'm working right now and
he goes like well you're threatening
with the metal object well that was the
worst part he's like i'm feeling
threatened by that put it down I was
like what are you gun dude picking up
trash do you have a gun you have a stun
gun II of a baton you have handcuffs you
have all these other weapons yeah and
I'm picking up trash he was they called
he resigned like a couple days later
some [ __ ] like that is I know he should
have been fired exactly and it's also
like when you when you watch that video
it's like people in the comments were
like well he should have been so mad why
he should've like told him where he
lived like you were saying [ __ ] like
that but it's also like he's being
approached aggressively exactly like
wouldn't you be [ __ ] pissed yeah
imagine if you [ __ ] you actually have
a reason to be somewhere you work there
you [ __ ] live there and someone is
testing getting harassed by anybody yeah
like well you wouldn't be mad like
what's the finance the biggest problem -
so when that video went down you see all
these cops he's yelling he's like I'm
working here I live here blah blah he's
like put the met he kept on saying metal
object because he knew what he was yes
he wasn't gonna say the the trash
picker-upper cuz it would make him sound
foolish I feel threatened by that
oh really exactly and then after this
whole thing what gets diffusing is
diffused because the administrator comes
in he goes I'm his mystery administrator
and he actually works so he goes okay
doesn't check his ID doesn't see if he
if he actually does work that you could
have been some random old white guy yeah
but doesn't want to see fair
vacation from him yeah like how my boy
was out of breath though when he pulled
up he was like yeah you can work there
he's an RA yeah yeah he's fine he works
yeah yeah and it's always he comes up he
goes and the cop is trying to justify
the situation he goes yeah so I verified
it you're okay try to be all good
and then the guy goes okay so we're okay
now so everything's fine he goes he goes
hey hey buddy Healy do you wanna do you
want to go back or do you want to
continue this he goes I'll continue what
he goes that use boy you had a metal
object meeting he goes what is it what
support what's it for
he goes you like you're escalating the
situation he goes what you can do it's
like clearly I'm not wrong what's this
metal object for you know what it's for
right and he can't say anything it's
like right he's like this is a bucket
that was my favorite it's a bucket like
if he's trying to rob something right he
wore a white bucket my stolen goods
I know what did you steal a standard
goldfish I sold a carnival down the
street and a bunch of marine rocks did
you see the one where it was like a like
like a we work or something like that
right like what do you caught like like
what was it old office that you had
cross campus cross camp it's like
something like that where everyone pays
rent
to get into the spot and they rent out
offices where they have their businesses
whatever that's their headquarters and
there was just one white dude and he was
like asking these three black dudes like
why are you guys here how'd you guys get
in here do you work here
do you have an office here like why are
you even here and they're like we can't
get into the [ __ ] building mm unless
we have a key yeah so we're here for a
[ __ ] reason dude we pay rent like
everybody else and he was like nope like
I don't believe you and he was giving
these guys such a [ __ ] hard time and
it's just so like like one hand up like
why dude yeah it's like you know you
know how to walk in this building you
can't when you ever you go into a
building like that you you don't just
walk in yeah you know what's up yeah you
need a check in your [ __ ] key you
need something there's so many problems
with the the whole system i I think I
don't think it needs to be completely
defunded and like abolish but there
definitely need to revamp the [ __ ] out
of that system and also there need to be
like these dudes need a you got a like
when I was listing the chocolate willing
you may be the best place yeah the
baby's like you should
take these guys out of the field
psychologically evaluate them train them
on how deescalate situations you should
have a lot it should be hard to be a cop
yeah they're not be easy know what you
should have like creme de la creme
people because it's a it's taxing on you
in a multiple ways one psychologically
just going out there thinking like I
could get shot today that's [ __ ]
taxing right on you whether you like
whether you're the strongest human or
not that's gonna [ __ ] wear on you
overtime to just having power in general
is that's hard that's like a hard thing
to deal with so like these [ __ ]
need to be like tip-top dude like in any
[ __ ] like anything like our asses
[ __ ] you're out dude gone you're no
longer you can't [ __ ] that you can't we
can't have any instances of [ __ ] and
that's the problem too is like even with
you and you take the police training
from a standpoint right like just
looking at just the training alone like
I've true I've trained with a lot of
cops I've coached a lot of cops and it's
a it's a very mixed bag you know like
you we get a lot of guys like we had one
guy start training with us cuz he had an
incident out in the field someone
reached for his gun and then he was like
I got out and he couldn't really stop on
me to learn how to do jujitsu here to
learn how to do all the stuff and he
started training was just which is great
for him like it's I'm glad that he took
that first step to do it because this
[ __ ] is not a game bro when you're when
you're playing with your life and you're
not ready to be in those situations
you're not ready to be wrestling and and
and in having someone on top of you
trying to [ __ ] beat the shadow you're
trying to kill you if you're not ready
to handle that with just the skill alone
then you have no reason to be out there
and when you watch certain videos of
cops like like handling certain
situations you could tell that
especially if it's a specific combat
situation like they're wrestling in
there and they're in there they're going
getting after each other you could tell
when somebody is very unprepared when
they don't they shouldn't be in that
position because they're not ready to be
in that position it's it's like it's
like imagine if I'm training somebody
and like their third week of transe
their sixth month of training they're
like oh I want to fight right most of
the time if I say all right go fight go
[ __ ] get punch in the face
and they're not seemed out on a regular
basis
even after six months of hard training
they're still probably not gonna be that
ready yeah you know and that's plain and
simple and it's not yeah it's a fight
situation but it's not far off from what
you're doing when you're restraining
people and you're having to control
somebody else's body yeah while they're
resisting and you have for their people
with you yeah you know and it's like you
could see those same situations and you
could tell that from a coach's eye it's
like oh this guy is not ready he's not
prepared you know like and how can you
be prepared in all those crazy
situations that cops have to deal with
because they deal with crazy [ __ ] that
we couldn't even fathom yeah but at the
same time they're going to those
situations and they're still not being
trained enough yeah you know like I've
trained like I've trained some cops that
some are like brown belts and some of
our blue belts and they they're they do
really well right and they don't they
know just enough to be able to restrain
somebody and be able to control somebody
else but then I've got some other people
who are like in the field and they're
cops and they don't know anything mm-hmm
and you know it's on an even playing
ground playing people when they get
surprised like for example there was a
one of the Gracie guys he's in the
corner of Brian Ortega Henner so Hannah
Gracie right so he does those you know
jujitsu breakdown yeah right that feels
so extra what that [ __ ] do by the way
okay guys so we're gonna see this video
yeah like we get it dude you're gonna
calm down before I choke you out I feel
like you're very likeable in general you
seem like a really nice guy so I got
this water that turns inside out yeah
yeah yeah I don't like I'd appreciate it
but you know as I kind of relax it's all
good okay but um yeah I like the guy but
a hundred does these you know these
break down videos and then I saw this
world really interesting one where a cop
is clearly clearly trained in jiu-jitsu
and he starts controlling the the
assailant right but people watch that
they're like oh that's really cool but
that should be the norm
exactly and you see how like less
violent it can be yeah obviously not all
situations but how less violent it can
be when somebody is trained and they're
ready to be able to have less than one
cop exactly and also think about like
think
about how before you were training the
fights you got into like that the the
way like just emotionally yeah I collage
eclis you're like huh now imagine you
also have a gun and a baton and now you
feel like as opposed to yeah what's
gonna happen if you screen and you've
been [ __ ] sparring you you at least
somewhat come cuz you had the physical
situation you have to put yourself in
the fire all the time emotionally
psychologically and easily exactly like
the other day yesterday
I haven't rolled and done jujitsu maybe
like two weeks and we roll pretty
frequently and these are all guys that
we've been training with for years and
and I was saying to my buddy Gabe big
dude strong guy and recently I told him
I was like look dude like I could I
realized that he was kind of taking easy
on me cuz he's a lot bigger guy dude
[ __ ] me up bro like put your weight on
me
use your strength like give me some work
you know yeah and I told that to him two
weeks ago and I roll with him again
completely regret telling him that
because it's substantially way harder
and when you and I train a lot and a lot
of times when I train with them like we
we like it's it's an even roll you know
like huh usually I get more dominant
position I don't sub the guy but it's
like I get more dominant positions but
it's like when I roll with him you never
know whose day it is right yeah and
yesterday I was wrong with his dude he
was on top of me and just putting all
his weight on me dawg I thought I almost
had a [ __ ] panic attack dog yeah I
almost had a [ __ ] pan this is a safe
controlled setting yeah it's like when
you feel like dude's weight and you're
tired and you know like oh [ __ ] I got
two more minutes on this round and this
dude's on top of me like giving me his
all and I'm feeling that and I feel like
I have nothing to give back
that's a [ __ ] scary situation and if
you're not if you're not used to that
feeling and you get put in that position
for the first time in your life that's a
bad spot to be in dude like there's
definitely like these situations to
where you know you go through these cops
scenarios right and you know I've spoken
to the police officers and I know that
all them told I don't know the exact
hours that they told me but the amount
of training that they have in terms of
like training people to be in those
physical situations it's the biggest
pile of [ __ ] I've ever heard in my
life yeah it's like these supposes
scenarios that might happen but you're
actually not doing it to somebody who's
struggling that's fighting that's giving
it their all right yes there
if you don't know what it feels by the
way if you guys have never try to
grapple or do anything for at least 15
seconds do you have no idea how
exhausting exactly yeah
hiring s [ __ ] especially when somebody
is frantic or they're on drugs you
really have to be on your yes you have
to be in shape you have to be doing your
conditioning you have to be doing your
strength training you have to you have
to be drilling techniques you have to be
doing all this stuff mm-hmm because if
it's at the end of the day like Tim
Kennedy has this great document on
YouTube where he trains civilians and he
trains people in the first responders
like police officers sheriff's things
like that and he's training these guys
and he's putting them putting them
through tough situations and he talks
about this he's like it's not the one
training session you missed
it's the years of training that you
didn't do the days and the months the of
all the accumulated training that you
didn't do and when you get put on a
position where your life is at stake
it's it's all for nothing because you
didn't put in the time because skills
are not built in just two-hour session
yeah right it's years and months and
unfortunately that's the way things are
and if you're not training on a constant
if you're not training on a regular
basis you're just probably not going to
be ready for the field and when you hear
guys like Jocko will Nick or guys like
Tim Kennedy guys have we've been to the
highest level of those situations of
like law like I guess law enforcement
and in a grand scheme of things yeah
it's like these guys know what works at
the highest level so we should be
listening to guys like this because
they're do it every single day they've
made their careers and their lives on it
and they know that training Jitsu and
training on a regular basis going to the
shooting ranges getting those rounds off
and and we're learning on a disc
deescalate and going through those
situations on a regular basis is
essential for their job and they'd
probably need to do that I also think
psychologically how how if you like say
you're comfortable would you just do and
grappling and stuff how easier it would
be for you to de-escalate a situation
where you could just talk it's like if
you're not worried about it you know
like if it gets there yeah I can handle
myself
I can now approach this with like a
little humor a little a hey what's going
on chuckling yeah you're under
yeah that was hilarious out of mine you
know have you [ __ ] funny you could
you can come in and not be even if the
guy starts being disrespectful to you
you don't you know like if it really
gets there I can take like I'll be okay
and I am a part but then again you are
that's that's that's best-case scenario
type cop right there are there are
there's the issue of there's a lot of
[ __ ] in the forest too that just
want to bully [ __ ] and yeah but
you got to get rid of those guys I just
think like the the things that are I
mean I haven't obviously seen a
spreadsheet of where the funding goes
right yeah but if there is an absorbent
amount of money for the police force I
don't think it's a defunding issue as an
allocation issue right where's this
money going to yeah is it going into
their mental health is it going into
their training first of all first the
first thing you need to do like you said
is assess all these cops that are that
are in these departments see take a look
at the track record if they have
multiple cases where people have
reported like racist issues where they
beat the [ __ ] out of some white Derek
Chavan whatever his [ __ ] exactly that
bit that God would you instant yeah we
looked at your record why don't you
explain the situation that's a problem
dude there's also also like are you
saying allocating resources like cops
don't need [ __ ] tanks exactly [ __ ]
you know that take the tank money and
invested in schools yeah put a smaller
tank like you know what I mean BOSU RPGs
who will [ __ ] killing like us on
another podcast too or we're talking
about how you know these cops aren't
really taught and the reason why I want
to bring a cop and ask them is this and
it's because I parted some other cops
it's like they don't really talk about
de-escalation yeah they they're actually
they're they're they're taught
escalation tactics is there certain
catch you on some exact trying to catch
technicality is it escalation tactic
you're not trying to bring the situation
down specifically what that guy in the
parking lot was drunk that was an
escalation tactic yeah take this
breathalyzer so I can get that number so
I could throw you in jail not listening
to what he's saying because he's worried
about but what did you drink exactly
what did you do look right and they
could have probably gone through the
right thing like they could pry him it I
don't know I don't know what the
situation would would have been what the
right thing would have been simple it
was when he said hey my sister lives
across the right right in the
neighborhood over here I'm gonna leave
my car here I can
comme if walking home was still a threat
to the neighborhood he's like cool I'm
gonna drive you to your sister's house
I'll take you there if it's right around
the corner it would take them a minute
yeah all right I'm gonna take you there
you're not gonna come out make sure that
you don't stay in the area for another
ten minutes see what's up yeah yeah done
it was like a gotcha moment yes when he
got made him do the breathalyzer yes I
got you like you didn't have to take you
to the drunk tank and you kind of see
like how like some situations on camera
you can kind of see like the look in
some of these guys his eyes when they
like cuff somebody and like it's like a
feeling of life and I realize that got
bodyslams you see that guy the guy that
was talking about like I went to the
Western Union and the guy came out of
nowhere
grabbed his arm and the guy that grabbed
him the cop that grabbed this poor dude
was a big [ __ ] guy yeah and he
slammed him on the ground and put all of
his weight on him but one he shouldn't
have done that
yeah cuz it was the wrong guy yeah
obviously shouldn't even happen we're
just having a conversation exactly look
but if they knew a little bit of martial
arts they knew something they could have
handled that situation a lot better
without slamming this poor [ __ ] guy
and breaking this guy's ready and I'm
[ __ ] identifying they didn't ask for
his identification exactly and now that
would have saved the county yeah [ __ ]
$700,000 lawsuit that's amazing right
it's like what are we doing here man and
and and and that's just talking from
like like an outside perspective of just
like skill-wise
yeah I saw another video of this black
dude a black cop and there's this black
lady and she was like pretty big she was
pretty tall and this white cop the black
cop is standing behind the black lady
the black lady like start a sock and his
dude the white cop boom boom boom and
you could tell the way that guy got hit
was like he's never been punched in the
face before one that's a problem right
obviously in that situation you're gonna
see hostile people they're gonna come at
you they're gonna attack you especially
as your job so you need to understand
how to one be able to stay calm in that
situation and not freak out mhm and from
my point of view it looked like a guy
that's never been punched in the face
yeah so immediately the situation
escalates tenfold so the guy behind the
black dude was like he socked her out
yeah yeah it was
reaction right and that's when things
that's when things shouldn't happen that
way do you think they should have been
able to restrain that lady properly yeah
probably
did she need to get knocked the [ __ ] out
and hit her head on the pavement cuz
what happens when she gets knocked out
hits right on the pavement she dies
that's a holding of the [ __ ] thing
mm-hmm right but it's like there has to
be another way another answer to be able
to handle the situations as soon as the
dude gets locked to the head he
should've been like double leg change
levels you know I mean like that's
that's one way to handle it and that
could have saved that situation from
happening you know and it's like there's
a lot of she's a complicated issue but
obviously easy for me to say from the
outside but from the point of view of
somebody that trains people in combat
that's an easy way to handle the
situation that's definitely part of the
solution for sure that's right yeah it
just seems a little too easy and
convenient to be a cop when you guys
don't even know how to do the basic of
basic stuff yeah it's like if if the
argument is like you don't know what we
go through our life is in constant
danger then why aren't you doing the
best to protect yourself exactly that's
the other side of it that's that's a
personal responsibility yeah that they
need to take care of themselves and the
guy that meant that did jujitsu because
he found himself an altercation that's
personal responsibility he said look
there's a glaring weakness in my job for
me to stay safe so I need to do this but
it should just be men it's okay exactly
you know I mean but good on him for for
realizing this and and and taking the
pom stuff and the cop training to is way
too short it's just a little bit you
know like I'm not obviously there's no
job that's the easiest to get yeah for a
job with that much power and
responsibility there should be way more
training like maybe they should be buds
training dude yeah like this [ __ ] they
put them in constant evaluation yeah
sorry three months or so doing bang
what's going on doctors get evaluated
they have to take a test consistently
for the rest of their life so they can
make sure that they can operate and you
know do whatever they can in their
practice they have to do this [ __ ] right
all the time CPAs have to take their
tests constantly yeah what about [ __ ]
cops man Yeah right like your job is
very dangerous like you said this isn't
coming from a civilian
yeah this is what you said you said it's
high pressure it's high stress and we
don't know what you're [ __ ] going
through well guess what tell us yeah and
if that's the case in that fast that
case then you really
need these parameters to make sure that
you could do your job well yeah and
that's it just isn't they're not taking
personal responsibility it's like well
exactly the world is cray and you know
what's so childish - it's like in
Atlanta when Rashard Brooks was killed
mm yes he was killed he was shot as he
was running away the what the Atlanta
cops are like well well now that well
since you guys want to defund us let me
show you guys what it's like not to have
any cops hmm they're like not taking
calls like when people are in trouble
they're like well let me show you guys
what it's like not to have cops it's
like that is the most childish you guys
are only further further improving our
point yeah how [ __ ] dumb you are
yeah people's lives at stake exactly
nobody's saying we don't need you we're
saying you need to do better at your job
exactly right and everybody needs to
hear that at-at this point here's the
[ __ ] funny million oh you're gonna
defund the [ __ ] police they're like
well good luck it's like how are we
gonna feed our families that's funny
because teachers get defunded all the
[ __ ] time and they're still working
yeah yeah they're doing a great job
so what the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah you know it's just dumb it's just a
bunch of whiny people who have a lot of
power that don't want to do better at
this point because they're comfortable
being at where they're at they're like
well you don't know what we go through
[ __ ] that excuse now you have to do
better exactly it's there's too much
power in that job for you not to be
doing 100% and definitely allocating the
resources back into the communities like
that's that's that's part of the - why
the fact that teachers get defunded all
the time is [ __ ] banana yeah I should
be the last thing that gets to [ __ ] yeah
and that's where people are talking
about as a shock allocate this money
it's like education starts first like
the family starts first like we people
cut kids people can make ends meet these
kids aren't getting the proper education
they don't have a lot of great teachers
put in place to make these kids succeed
yeah it starts there man yeah we should
probably start there so they don't end
up in a position where they're here
either right yeah a lot of problems -
what we came ago talked about the prison
system so a lot of people don't know
with Rashard Brooks
Rashard Brooks was on TV not too long
ago before that instant had been talking
about how he's a reformed convict and
then it's hard for him to get a job
right which is [ __ ] - which is such
[ __ ] so when he was running away he
was worried about his future he's like
look it's already hard for me to get a
[ __ ] job
right right and they're arresting him on
a [ __ ] DUI yeah which he yeah it was
wrong right right but he parked
car he was sleeping in his [ __ ] car
right what the [ __ ] that's the most
responsible thing to do when you're
drunk I feel like if I was a cop and I
saw my man like our brother let's go
it's like a blur you know where are you
so you don't have to leave your car here
I'm gonna take you away Yeah right and
if you would have been like okay I got
you like cool I don't take you to a
drunk tank Yeah right just put it over
there exactly I came back home but
you're right you touched on an important
thing to the the the prison system like
the fact that you come out and you're
you can't really get a job like what do
you like this is gonna Neville if you're
a criminal or you went to jail for doing
some crime and you guys my options when
you get out and you can easily get
violated on probation or parole yeah
it's like I can't get a job I need to
[ __ ] eat ya got bills like what the
[ __ ] I gotta do something well it's a
signal issue it's like once you're once
you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] for life and
that's a problem it's they call it a
Correctional Facility why it's not a
Christmas you're not helping these
[ __ ] no no not at all and
especially one it's like nonviolent
crimes like selling weed or whatever
what the [ __ ] are you doing you know
it's crazy that you can't vote when you
when you're a felon - yeah yeah I was
I'm pretty sure that that's the thing
but yeah like what the [ __ ] why why why
do you lose your right to vote that's
yeah that's weird what's gonna happen
yeah it's weird it's really weird but
there's just a lot of [ __ ] with
money in positions of like lobbyists and
and have the Year politicians that
that's like where the Perot I just wish
I was Superman I couldn't be killed or
nothin
yeah I'll just be like hey fix this [ __ ]
or I'm a laser blast all you
[ __ ] okay all right that's when
I get the tanks that's the police don't
get those tanks yeah thinks I'm gonna
blow them up with my laser beam on mana
solutions this is modern solutions but
the other thing though - about like some
guys that I've talked to that like we're
interested in becoming cops I'm like so
like what makes you want to become a cop
like like what's your mindset like going
in and they're like I remember this one
dude it was very because I was like mom
that's kind of [ __ ] up but like I
remember him just like kind of staring
off like into the distance and he just
goes you know like I just I just want to
see some action you know I mean like
that feeling you get like that's that's
what it's about
yeah no you should not be a cop out of
my head right in my head I was like dude
someone [ __ ] canceled this guy you
know like
that's your visit a lot of people like
that because I had that uh the the it's
got Cosmo this dating guy and a lot of
his clients um who's dating coach are
cops
mmm-hmm and you know and again it's that
conversation they say like there's
always something about like these
[ __ ] need to be put away
immediately probable is hyper aggressive
[ __ ] and bullying or something it's like
you were not in the right my safe to be
a [ __ ] job right should be to protect
and serve my community I want to make
sure people are safe yeah right why not
why is that not the answer I'm just
ready to [ __ ] somebody up dog when you
go into a situation like that it's
already bad right and I'm sure there's
times where they have to go in a
situation like that because you know
it's they have to predict themselves a
certain point but at the same time it's
like like going back to what Jacko said
on the Joe Rogan podcast he was saying
when he was in Iraq they had to go and
build relationships with the community
that they were serving and servicing and
they got to know all the people because
there's good people in the community any
community go to you're gonna find those
people to help you understand exactly
and it provides context yeah and that's
what's important is that sometimes when
you come into a situation they don't
have the context going in and then it
makes it a lot harder yeah if you're
trolling a certain area right and you go
to these community events you start
knowing people unless their [ __ ] goes
down it's like oh I know that guy
yeah it's like what do you think about
this person they could have these
conversations and allows them to assess
the situation it actually keeps you more
safe exactly cuz you become a part of
this community my parents have opened
our business in you know not a great
area of Sacramento but we've been
relatively pretty good because we've
been there for so long and we know
people in the community yeah
and they know yeah they know you guys so
people leave us alone so we've been
there for like 30-something years and
nothing has really happened to us yeah
you know so like and that's the
difference is is understanding your
community and being a part of the
community yeah if you're just some
outsider coming in then you're not
wanted exactly they're gonna always see
you and if you're not making the effort
to be a part of the community they don't
want you either yeah I wouldn't want
some [ __ ] dude to come up at no
one tell me how to [ __ ] live my life
exact you know what sucks to us cuz I
have I went to high school to student he
became a cop and he's a really nice dude
and I've seen him because he works this
out fast I was there and he was just
like him and another cop were just kind
of walking down the street but they were
doing exactly that they were just like
talking with people shooting the [ __ ]
yeah like laughing and stuff like with
random people at a coffee shop and I was
like
was like kind of like that's what they
should be doing like that's a cool [ __ ]
they're just like laughing having a good
time
bah bah bah and then they were just guys
take care better me out like just a
quick like five minute [ __ ] chat
what's going on how are you guys Bob cuz
I got it's just touch base it's really
good because I'm at a point to when I
see a cop I don't wanna [ __ ] talk to
this thing look over oh yeah it's like I
don't want to have a car like how you
doing I'm like stuck pig Yeah right and
I got my ass beat like yeah cuz I'm
black and I'm gonna throw them at that
weird little softball that what yeah
black mother okay we on here yeah I'm
crazy like you're going to jail it's
like I probably am ha provoked this
situation yeah what - [ __ ] and
like it's so crazy how like that's the
oldest running joke of all time yeah
he's like police brutality oh yeah
against black people like that's that's
the oldest running joke and everybody no
matter if people want to deny it or not
when they hear Dave Chappelle talk about
it or Chris Rock talked about it
everybody's laughing cuz everybody knows
everybody knows the jokes real [ __ ]
everybody knows the joke was funny is my
dad so my dad my dad was a great dude
but he was never the most law-abiding
citizen like he would always get like
got into fights growing up and you know
yeah double-double dance machete Dibble
death
so he'd that he hated cops my dad hated
absolutely hated cops like he would
always like he'd be like please Patrick
whatever you do just don't be a cop yeah
he would always tell me like I knew if I
wanted to break his heart you know like
I always knew that was in my back pocket
but it was funny cuz like we were having
this conversation and cuz he's been he's
had a lot of issues with cops like back
in the day like you would like have like
gotten fights with cops and stuff like
that this is back in like the 50s when
like yeah you could do that in like yeah
yeah like you didn't go to jail for like
some reason but yeah so he just didn't
like him and I remember having this
conversation and he was kind of like he
was being genuine he was I don't
understand like why like you know like
I'm I get harassed to like I'm white and
I get harassed all the [ __ ] time and
I remember being like yeah that's it no
one should get harassed but I remember
thinking like what's cuz also like
you've committed crimes
you know another record arrest when they
look at your ID and they say this
[ __ ] of
nice guy is a [ __ ] rap sheet a
literal rapture as I this kid was
walking home from the grocery store yeah
you are not the same maybe should be a
sharp kid man yeah and the other thing
though to like everyone keeps talking
about is like the whole [ __ ]
statistic like you know actually white
people get killed more by cops than then
black people do though a lot but I know
but people say that [ __ ] little white
people more white people so it's not a
contest
eggs exactly and it's like don't you
think that that's wrong
like should there be that many people
getting killed by Mexican doesn't matter
no one should be getting killed by it's
it's not just a like them problem it's a
everyone's problem saying like we have
an issue of rhetoric too right because
people seem to be okay with that
situation when they say well walls like
well if you're gonna get [ __ ] over
then all of us should get [ __ ] over no
it's like nobody should get [ __ ] all
right you shouldn't be okay with your
your brother or your kin or somebody
else getting [ __ ] over as long as
everybody gets [ __ ] over equally yeah
that's a dumb thing to say yeah right
people should be treated fairly equally
don't be okay with the lowest status quo
like why the [ __ ] and you know that just
shows that people just get into
semantics all the time yeah they're not
trying to figure out a solution right
they're not trying to figure they're not
really hearing what you have to say
either like they're not hearing what
other people have to say about like the
BLM movement and like the police
brutality movement and all that stuff
like they're not trying to hear you out
they're just trying to be like well I
think you're being a crybaby and
actually this is this is what it really
is
see this was somebody just needs to [ __ ]
one of their children and give them
interracial babies and then be like well
I can see how your daughter's free to
see how your sons treated and the way oh
maybe now I see you find [ __ ] yeah that
should be the goal dude just throw a
bunch of black Asian and Mexican people
just [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of white
people yeah consensually at age and
marrying them in love yeah do you
believe in Christ good
[Laughter]
fucking-a we start a band what the [ __ ]
what's our band gonna be called dude
[ __ ] the evolution Wow seven seven
seven oh yeah we should I get four more
guys and we're in dude perfect what's
that alex is gonna be the the singer the
drummer or the rapper the rep range the
rookies elaborate his rapper me and Pat
will like we'll be like the roadies and
like occasional be makers but like will
not be the go-go dancer for some reason
I feel like this is easy
yeah right there I feel like I could
just you know dance any style that I
wanted to do and if go-go dancing was
the style I can excel at that you know
si si yeah I know in the the previous
podcast we talked about Chris D'Elia and
[ __ ] but I wonder if like Ari Shaffir is
kind of like it's my time to come back
he's been coming around I've been seeing
him post stuff oh really
I've seen like some stuff don't forget
about that [ __ ] so quick that's crazy
how fast [ __ ] like that hey I wonder if
the crystal a thing like if this is how
long that's gonna stay with him like I
wonder after like say where he's gonna
be in the next like six months our
people are still gonna remember him for
that little slip-up that he had or this
incident whether whether it's true or
not like I wonder what's gonna happen
this is always I think gonna stain them
no matter even if he proves what the
emails or whatever they have because
like with the louis c.k thing like I
wonder how long for him to it's like how
long is he gonna he'll never get he'll
never get back to like Dave Chappelle
status right he's not gonna be whenever
he goes yeah he's gonna he's gonna do
well continually in terms of like he'll
book out his venues he'll make his money
he'll still be able to do what he wants
but every time the topic of louis c.k
comes up that's gonna come out first but
Louie ankle did you guys see those now
here's a new special you don't know
dropped it like at the beginning in
quarantine yeah he just you just dropped
that what the [ __ ] yeah it was actually
sick I liked it I Renny so many talks
about it watch it watch it
you know politicians around let me tell
you something here I do not agree with
louis c.k I think he is a trash bag and
I will never support what's the West
what's the website called Louie CK hey
kid calm Louie Kate Louie CK George calm
I'm talking about man yeah but he he
talks
like he has he has bits about like
everything that curious to see what it
is
additional I can give it a one-star on
rotten tomato yes Wow
what if what if he think you think was
really funny and it's really good I will
not because I do not care for him and in
fact I do not listen to our Kelly
anymore it's the remix to ignition I did
not ah that song so good this guy's a
good politician it is Achatz I had no
idea special that came out yeah came out
I heard thingy in April I heard season
two of surviving art Kelly came out a
while there's a season yeah I mean
here's the thing dude he's done he's
done like eating a dead horse yeah well
even the first document that they put
out they dragged it out really and they
could have made it concise with the same
stories and just made it hit way harder
yeah they're trying to pull this out for
money and that's where I'm just like
now you're just kind of not taking this
[ __ ] seriously like yeah like come on
you're just learning it you're splitting
this is a very serious situation this is
everybody
yeah yeah well guys well that rest of
this episode you know what everybody who
listen to this podcast like ugh dude you
guys and on the weirdest no we do like
well [ __ ] aren't killing the Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ
yeah well guys a great Bieber impression
make sure it on Sundays you guys go to
church and thank you for listening to
the genius brain pod cast we got Nick
the ear we also got Patrick T Riley you
can find them on Instagram and Nick the
ear and Patrick T Riley ye so give them
a go the big mad podcast they haven't
put out an episode in 17 days but they
will eventually yeah baby come on and
again we have to do in a person this
time we're not doing the zoom stuff
anymore so yeah the zoom [ __ ] kind of
sucks
perfect we'll see y'all next time peace